mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
je nachdem wie die lage ist so um die 80
verdachtsmomente des kurses zu werden
74 warum das alte netz für morgen
hertz strategie wie das funktionieren
soll zwischen
vier soziale kontakte und viel bewegung
zu gut die strategie hat und ich mein
tisch wenn man das doch nicht bereit
einfach fällt die werte mit florian a
also lässt man jüngste pandemie
statistiken außer acht dann kann man
festhalten in der schweiz steigt die
durchschnittliche lebenserwartung bei
geburt seit jahrzehnten
und damit stellt sich natürlich auch die
frage nach der kunst des alterns dem
widmen wir uns heute herzlich willkommen
bei kulturplatz
[Musik]
nun wie gelingt würdiges gutes schönes
alter nicht treffe gleich eine frau die
vielleicht den einen oder anderen kniff
auf lager hat ulla k sitz ist 96 jahre
alt und gemäß kinos buch der rekorde die
älteste trans lehrerin der welt einst
war sie selbst schülerin der
ausdruckstanz ikone greta luckhardt und
sie unterrichtet heute noch viermal pro
woche ausdruckstanz respekt wir fliegen
weil durch die nicht
durch
[Musik]
doch nick war wie durchgang
und da unterrichtet sie nach wie vor mit
größter passion derweil hatte ich mit
meinem 40 lenzen mit ersten grauen
strähnchen geradezu lächerlich ich weiß
besonders in anbetracht der tatsache
dass ich diese haare dereinst vielleicht
verlieren werde oder die zähne und heben
das gewicht auf das linke und das rechte
bein alt gut welt hoch
und altern bedeutet verlust verlust von
vitalität von beweglichkeit von
geistigen fähigkeiten und natürlich von
liebgewonnenen menschen welche
strategien helfen mit solchen zumutungen
umzugehen optimistisch und bestenfalls
humorvoll zu bleiben
ich nehme mir die freiheit
menschen
nachts alle spieler
sich die ganze bandbreite von
menschlicher leben fasziniert mich nach
wie vor
wir können viel verändern wenn wir mehr
ältere menschen zeigen das leben
jenseits der vierzig oder fünfzig das
ist nämlich ganz wunderbar
früher marlies alt sein vorbereitung auf
das ende heute ist es ein versprechen
wenn es gut läuft mit 90 noch aktiv mit
70 so glücklich wie mit 17 zu sein
mit den alten müssen wir rechnen auch in
der neuen staffel von heidi klums show
germany's next topmodel
drei kandidatinnen haben die 50
überschritten
zwei davon laufen locker auf die 70 zu
verändert sich unser blick aufs alter
gerade radikal
[Musik]
lust auf die schönheit des alters machen
das möchte dennis burcons aus amsterdam
früher war sie selber model und
arbeitete in der branche als fotografin
heute nach einer krise sucht sie nach
menschen die etwas zu geben haben zeigt
uns kluge ältere frauen in voller blüte
die den weg in die zukunft weisen
vorbilder in der neuen disziplin auf
gute weise alt werden
wenn du den menschen eine andere vision
fürs leben gibt und auch die positive
seite des älterwerdens zeigst dann haben
sie immerhin eine wahl
denn klar jung sein ist wunderbar aber
älter sein ist anders wunderbar
auch auf ihrem instagram kanal platziert
sie ganz bewusst ihr bild der kohlen
alten frau die gesellschaft braucht pro
aging stadt anti aging ein gefühl für
die vorteile des alters
ich glaube wirkliche älter wir werden
desto mehr werden wir wir selbst dann
können wir all die dinge über bord
werfen von denen wir glaubten dass wir
sie tun mussten weil die gesellschaft
unsere eltern oder sonst wer sie von uns
erwarten und dann kommt freiheit
freiheit
narrenfreiheit
der film die herbstzeitlosen brachte es
vor gut 15 jahren auf den punkt
alter heißt auch immer weniger zu
verlieren haben
eine gelassenheit die man auch
zelebrieren kann
[Musik]
wie so viele absprachen wurden auf der
straße auf der film für junge menschen
august
ich glaube alt werden ist gar nicht so
schlimm weil es unter druck was man
selber daraus macht also es ist so wie
wenn plötzlich so alte menschen auf ganz
neue art war nur werden wenn sie sich
öffnet misstraue ich wirklich neues
anfangen heidi maria glössner bleibt
neugierig gierig auf neues bald ist
wieder premiere in bern ich komme heißt
das stück über drei generationen von
frauen
auch wenn glasner ein vorbild für viele
ist auch wenn ihr kein mensch glaubt
dass sie nächstes jahr 80 wird mit
verlusten umgehen muss sie dennoch
das ist das abgeschiedene rundung
da wird ja welt um eine um die
persönliche welt wird immer ärmer und
das ist der traurige teil der vom
älterwerden aber das gehört leider dazu
und man das akzeptieren
[Musik]
wenn wir länger leben wie verbringen wir
die lange zeit viele wollen viel reisen
bewegen vor allem sich selbst dabei
könnten sie so viel anderes bewegen
das meint ludwig hasler und träumt davon
dass sich seine altersgenossen befreit
vom kurzen tag des arbeitslebens um die
wirklich wichtigen dinge kümmern
die eigene website
zukunft ist zur kupfer der junge
das
eigentlich so richtig vergnügen vom
dazu kommt der pid rosiger aussieht als
ihm eigentlich wird der mensch muss
etwas vorhaben alte sollten in schulen
aushelfen weiters land oder mit kindern
zeit verbringen deren eltern entlasten
oder gemeinsam mit der jugend lösungen
fürs klima suchen er selbst hält
unermüdlich vorträge sucht kontakt zu
den jungen regelmäßig schreibt er der 50
jahre jüngeren journalistin samantha
zaugg einen brief und sie antwortet aus
der sicht ihrer generation
funksignale zwischen den planeten jung
und alt
bisher als zeitungskolumne jetzt wird
ein buch daraus
das hat sehr gut da kranke erste brief
geschrieben als olivia samantha und das
thema wasser als und schloss kann ich so
gut wird ich sage gönnerhaft ganz
erstaunt es mich wundern was dazu kommt
eine flasche rotwein
das ist als schönes und so fährt er
konnte die antwort und die tests als
erster was händen alter eigentlich immer
mit dem blöden rot wie
und das doch alle christen funktioniert
wenn es normal wird dass wir 90 werden
heißt das 25 geschenkte jahre nach der
pensionierung
das skript des alterns muss
umgeschrieben werden meint ludwig hasler
und er denkt ganz neue
rollenverteilungen zwischen den
generationen
gerade in der arbeitswelt
die jungen stecken voller frischem
wissen und enthusiasmus die alten aber
haben das was vielfach unterschätzt wird
man nennt es erfahrung erfahre ich ob
ich wohl nicht kalt werden müssen tätige
gesellschaft moment mache ich alles
lernt man erwirbt sich fachkompetenzen
zu wickeln sie können das gitter in
erfahrung dass sie nicht lernen sondern
erfahrungen machen
insofern ist es ist natürlich so lang
lebt einfach im vorteil
[Musik]
und diesen vorteil wissen viele schon
sehr aktiv zu nutzen
jetzt sehen wir sie auch stärker in der
öffentlichkeit
sie sind vorbilder für gelassenheit mit
einer kraft die ansteckend sein kann
[Musik]
lukas ist schön im schlaf für
zusätzliche jetzt könnt ihr sage wie
schön die sogenannt ruhige kugel
schieben sie unterrichtet aber noch
warum was geht's immer und der rechte
ist mit lava also ich war immer
unterrichtet wird bis ich zwischendurch
mal dran sein aber ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen nicht zu unterrichten ich
muss das machen also ich bleibe dabei es
ist immer gut sie ein schülerinnen und
schüler über sagt klar begleiter wie
wichtig ist und hat das soziale im
moment mitglied über die passion vom
tanzen mit ihnen teilt man mir macht es
freude macht wirklich gerne die stunde
und merck auf wie die schüler mit bad
und wc und für mich ist das
die central ist es bin älter werde dass
man ebenso wichtig ist auch loslassen
ich nicht so einfach nur sauer das ist
es wo es auch im alter lehrer loslassen
ich habe vieles müssen los nach aber wer
sagt es gehört zu dem prozess von yahoo
teil dieser welt es wird absolut dazu ja
ja und würde sich bestätigen dass man im
alter auf freiheit gewöhnt doch doch ich
muss das jetzt nicht ich kann das machen
muss es nicht mit bewege ich einfach
leichter zu machen dass lepper ja ich
schaffe so lange ich kann und das noch
immer noch obwohl dann körperlich jetzt
einiges um mehr schaffen macht aber ich
nehme so einfach ist
day
er ist alt er ist weiß und ein mann
seine privilegien aber die habe er sich
verdient meint der wahl st galler helge
timmerberg
nun schonungslosigkeit gehört zu den
markenzeichen des reisejournalisten und
bestseller autors und schonungslos ist
auch mit sich selbst etwa in seinem
neuen buch darin geht es um drogen um
abenteuer und ums altern legkow mio
70 werden ich weiß noch mal sitzt
helge timmerberg
70 und in höchstform globetrotter von
berufswegen seit jahrzehnten schreibt er
über die große weite welt sein jüngstes
buch ist eine reise zu sich selbst und
zum nahen dohlen gestern in st gallen
[Musik]
ich hatte mal ein bauch in st gallen und
schleppte ihn wie ein bierkasten die
treppen hoch die treppen haben 163
stufen denn sie führen von der altstadt
zum rosenberg hinauf wo ich wohne ich
hätte auch auf richtigen straßen mit dem
auto fahren können oder mit dem bus aber
ich hatte das treppen verseuchte
dohlengässle zu meinem fitness parcours
erklärt am anfang war ich mit pixel also
ich kann eigentlich in einem zug
es geht ja in dem kapitel in meinem
bauch den ich hatte 20 kilo zu viel und
mit wachsender konditionen brauchte ich
mich dann noch nicht mehr festhalten
irgendwann also den dem dohlengässle
habe ich eigentlich jetzt ganz gutes
herz zu verdanken bauch beine po alles
alles darf und so
fit starker raucher genüsslicher käfer
timmerberg konsumiert seit mehr als 50
jahren
ein langes schriftsteller leben unter
substanzen da hätte sich konsequent und
seine vorbilder
was meine vorbilder einte war ihre
einstellung zu arbeits drogen es gab die
trinker wie hemingway um bukowski die
cook sowie hunters thompson stephen king
die maschinisten die hans fallada und
williams büro ich dagegen fühlte mich zu
den quellen der inspiration von hesse
und buttlar hingezogen das waren die
käfer
kenne eigentlich keinen in meinem alter
der soll jetzt völlig abstinent durch
die gegend geht wieder sowieso nur
sondern dem sich alle an gewöhnt sich an
irgendetwas zu gewöhnen und so und das
lässt nicht plötzlich mehr in die
kreativität in der sich bin beim
schreiben oft selbst überrascht
eine ganz andere schleife als geplant
und das macht den spaß beim schreiben
aus und das macht auch die spannung aus
glauben und die nüchternen
ökonomischer natürlich ganz klar aber
die kann ich ihn lesen zu langweilig
thema berg bringt als junger journalist
in den 1980 er jahren den sogenannten
new journalism nach europa eine radikal
neue subjektive form der
berichterstattung als junger gegen das
establishment
so hielt er es und damit hat er auch im
höheren alter keine probleme das problem
hätten die jungen
ich bin weiß ich bin alt ich bin ein
mann und meine privilegien habe ich mir
verdient das privileg der jungen ist der
ozean an leben den sie noch vor sich
haben unverdient der ist ein geschenk
mein vorschlag zur güte wäre dass jeder
seine privilegien genießt und keiner den
anderen zu quatschen dafür habe ich
einfach zu wenig zeit
das ist weniger das problem dass wir
alten die jugend nicht verstehen einen
jungen verstehen uns alten nicht weil
wir können nach sie nachvollziehen weil
wir haben das schon erlebt aber die
jungen verstehen uns nicht weil die sind
ja noch nicht alt geworden die haben ja
noch gar nicht mitgekriegt wie das ist
die realitäten von familie arbeit
überleben kann na da und das kann ein
jugendlicher nicht verstehen weil diese
erfahrung musste er noch machen bald hat
helge timmerberg das steile dohlengässle
1 wieder einmal bezwungen kurz vor dem
gipfel glück dieses eine große thema
es war nie mein plan uhr alt zu werden
auch jetzt ist er es nicht ab 70 ist für
mich jeder tag ein guter um zu sterben
weil ich doch schon so viel erlebt habe
so hörte ich mich ziemlich oft reden
wenn mich jemand nach meiner angst vor
dem tod befragt ich habe sehr viel
respekt oder auch angst vor der
vergreisung also ich hab immer brennen
vom tod wohl weil weil für mich ist der
tod der tod da kommt nichts mehr nach
dem punkt mehrere leute geschrieben die
77 sind die sagen ja wir machen uns auch
große gedanken drüber oder so
und ich denke dass das geht so
vielleicht in 15 jahren los oder so
etwas bis dann muss ich mir noch mal
einen echt guten plan ausdenken es sei
denn das leben entscheidet anders und
auf dem boden gesehen geht plötzlich das
licht aus
[Musik]
mladic ist in deutschland aufgewachsen
ihre jungen jahre waren vom krieg
geprägten alltag in trümmern mittendrin
entdeckte sie den tanz als berufung war
schülerin der berühmten gerät palucca
1949 kam sie für ein engagement in die
schweiz ans stadttheater bern wo sie den
bekannten komponisten und dirigenten tae
bok kasich kennen und lieben lernte die
beiden heirateten und bekamen zwei söhne
hier in ihrem zuhause fortuna kasich
täglich den ofen an früher im
kriegsversehrten deutschland hatte sie
sich die tanzstunden bei gerät palucca
mit holzkohle verdient dass sie klaute
sie zusammen um damit das tanzstudio zu
heizen
[Musik]
als sie endlich erlaubt einige
schicksalsschläge sind später ihren mann
verloren einen ihrer söhne trotz all der
tragöde könnte aussage größeren sich
gehen geradezu schicksalsschlag einmal
kraft und resilienz im alter
auf ein auto er denke aber es ist danach
verpflichten wie geschaffen also jene
von denen beide verloren aber eigentlich
auch weil er finde ich bin da hat als
allem der basler muss ja das mache und
dass man dir aber wieder so machen was
hat sie so schwer kein ist für den
lebensabschnitt freude an dem was man
macht freude daran aber es kann hp den
schülern wenn er spüre er sich für
schuldig dass ich noch weitermachen
ich glaube das hilft einem show also es
ist keines ist nicht so wichtig
[Gelächter]
jetzt haben wieder freut winnenden
valletta biologisch aber ich habe mit
ins kino also mich interessieren alle
noch was läuft und nicht einfach jetzt
für mich war und nur das machen sondern
auch wieder ob es oft so sieht sie also
aus schmidt junge menschen raphael
austausch mit jungen menschen doch dass
ich berufsschule selber begleitet haben
und führt jetzt seien es weniger mit
jungen liebst du mehr mit dem song geht
es auch um sie herum hat oder ist der
usa
morgan junge frau seit maximal 40 sie
werden nach maria mühe machen was würde
sie jeder sage das ist
einfach ein kurz
da kann man gar nicht reden wenn es da
die mieter was ich mehr bin als sehr
schwierig vorstellbar ist dass
freundeskreis
liebt man das ist eher traurig man sich
ehrlich sagen also durch mehr
viele ältere leute richtet dann erlanger
unter werden und die kann sich
christian lüth quasi überlebt wie tolle
zeit trotzdem der mitte der optimismus
wie die machen einfach gerne meter
schaffe so lange ich kam aber ich habe
nie irgendein rezept
geht alles was die angst vorhand cross
karts
und
vor zwei tagen habe ich seit ich mutter
alleine oder als gemacht waren sich
gange und die friedliche
wieder
habe immer durst aber das eben die wahl
schwer so entspannend das sind so ganz
kleine
bringt ja aber sie sind doch die grenze
komme ja ja ja
danke firma
ein junger mann der ganz gezielt den
kontakt zu älteren menschen sucht ist
der künstler gabriel kessler immer mit
dabei pinsel und leinwand
aber ich bin nie gabriel und ich bin
kunstmaler
[Musik]
ich bin da im plan bis nördlicher autos
ein hermelin und
male das treffen
[Musik]
in helmand papiere
20 wirklich dass rotenburg original
chocolaterie peitsche und ist sehr
sozial also und sozial
künstlerisch sammler zum beispiel papier
antec allee und macht so wenig gesperrt
ist und er auf den komplexen darum sie
michael jacksons vor bleibt
das landwirtschaftliche was ein herr
mohring ist es altersheim für
früheren dafür ehemalige verdient weil
man hatte auch nach der halbzeit regals
nur danke
sagen für alle aber es ist so dass gar
nur eigenhandel sind ich kann heute
nicht gewohnt und bin dann mal weg
laufen und haben die briten haben da
ganz interessante gesichter gesehen und
spannen die
charaktere und um die nicht an der
hohlen hand
gemachter
abschlussprojekt
erzählte geschichte ich bin eine
landschaft wo es ganzes leben trainieren
verborgen ist
also ich finde ich mit viel weisheit
verbunden und ich freue mich vor allem
als alte freue mich
wenn ich immer mehr falten
im gesicht aber abzeichnet im minus
ist der fleck die collection warum bin
ich darüber zu lernen vor der ältere
menschen die crew das tut mir als jungem
mann stellte der heutige schnelllebige
zeit wo alles extrem schnell gut und
extreme bilderflut herrscht ja oft an
immer genau weiß wo du warst mir nach
hause und dann do kann hier in ruhe gut
[Musik]
wie kommst du ja
ja sie mit cola kasich habe ich
definitiv ein neues rohr morgen gefunden
und ich merke mir ihre worte ohne mut
und humor geht gar nichts und auch nicht
ohne dass man sagt was man will um das
lustvolle leben geht es jetzt gleich
hier im anschluss bei der sternstunde
philosophie und der kulturplatz der
meldet sich in einer woche wieder dann
geht es bei uns um inklusion um
tänzerinnen mit prothesen etwa oder
schauspieler im rollstuhl dann meiner
kollegin eva wannenmacher und ich sage
auf basis
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos